(upbeat music)
- Welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
Today, I'm honored and
privileged to host Sean Astin
for a conversation about mental health,
resources advocacy and support.
Sean's someone who's probably
known to all if not or many,
if not all of you but I'm gonna go ahead
and give my really brief introduction.
So Sean Astin is an American film actor,
director, voice artists, producer,
who's best known for his roles
in films like "The Lord
Of the Rings Trilogy",
"The Goonies" of course, "Rudy"
and also in a Netflix six
series, "Stranger Things Two".
He's a son of Academy Award
winning actress, Patty Duke,
and acclaimed actor, John Astin.
He's also won several different awards.
"The Lord of the Rings
Trilogy" garnered eight
or 11, excuse me, 11 Academy Awards.
And Sean also has taken home awards for,
he had the standard award
for best supporting actor,
awards from the Las Vegas
Film Critics Society.
the Seattle Film Critics,
the Utah Film Critics Association,
and the Phoenix Film Critics Society.
So obviously someone who's talented
in his field and in his vocation.
He's also a long distance runner.
has been a long distance
runner since his teens,
and in 2012, Astin launched
a Twitter campaign,
hashtag Run3rd as a way
to dedicate his runs
to causes and ideas that
matter not only to him
but to others as well.
He's a UCLA graduate who
has served on the board
of several different national
nonprofit organizations,
including the National
Center For Family Literacy.
He's a vocal advocate for literacy,
mental health awareness, bipolar disorder,
civic engagement and several other issues.
So I'm honored to welcome, Sean Astin
to the Addy Hour podcast.
Thanks so much for being here.
- Its so nice to hear you read all that.
I just made it feel so I don't
know, substantial somehow.
That's nice. Thank you for that.
- It is substantial.
Substantial and real.
(both laughing)
- It's real.
But definitely appreciate, you know,
all the work that you've
done over the years
in so many different spheres,
not just in terms of
obviously your talent,
onscreen and offscreen but also just
the way you've been a real
advocate for mental health.
And I know there's a story there
that we'll get into as well.
But as my listeners know,
I often just like to
check in and kind of see
how my guests are doing
in the midst of everything
that we're facing in this
ever-changing world and emerging,
trying to emerge from COVID.
So I just wanted to start there
and see how you're doing
these days overall.
- Well, thank you for that.
As people are watching this,
I'm currently sitting in a little
cottage in Sweden
and there at any moment I
fully expect one of these big,
you know like cruise ships that go by.
They're like dinner cruise,
but they're the size of big cruise ships.
I am back to life,
I would say, you know,
I went and made a movie in Louisiana
and in the film industry
there's all sorts of COVID
protocols that films take.
But it was weird.
It was definitely weird to do
that first sort of, you know,
I was at the airport with crowds
and in the airport shuttle
to the rental car with,
you know, crowded buses
and just thinking what,
you know, what has happened
to my consciousness?
This is not just fear of
you know, of getting COVID,
it's also my relationship,
all of our relationship to each other
and to the outside world.
And so that was a culture
shock after a year and a half.
And then, then when I came
back, my wife and kids are like,
"You can't come in yet,
you have to stay next door.
You don't have to get like
an Airbnb for a few days,
so you can be tested."
And so I did that and now
I'm over here doing these
conventions that are like autograph,
you know, science fiction,
fantasy comic book, you know,
Comicon kind of conventions.
So there it's a lot of people,
so it's gonna be and I did it in Sweden
and then I'm going to do Wales.
So I don't know,
I feel like the treadmill
has started back up.
I'm back on it.
You know, I'm getting this a
Master's in Public
Administration, Public Policy
from American University
and I am spending all of my
discretionary time on, you know,
reading and studying and quizzes
and midterms and all that.
So life is good.
Life is good.
It's the best is that I'm
able to like get outside
and do long walks and stuff.
So, but it's hard.
The hardest part is family.
Is managing family.
But everybody seems to be in a mode.
You know, the middle kid is
so I've got three daughters.
Allie, Elizabeth and Isabella,
Allie lives with her boyfriend
and they have their own place now.
They were with us for a
long time during COVID
and then they got their own place.
And then Elizabeth is still at home.
She's at Pepperdine and
she's still at home.
So wait, I'm figuring any minute,
that'll be both she and the youngest one
who's 16 are at home so
it's gonna be amazing to see what happens
when we're no longer living
in a submarine environment.
You know, where you just,
where you're outside of our cohort.
And who knows what that holds in store.
But life is good, long
answer to a short question.
- I appreciate that honesty.
And just taking us
through that journey too.
I mean, it sounds like
some of it's pacing too,
you know, as you know,
the families kind of all
been together I'm assuming
more often than before
from the way that you've characterized it.
But even as you are emerging kind of...
- I actually, for a long time,
I would mourn the end of COVID
because it would likely
mean that we'd never spend
that kind of close time
together ever again.
So in that sense, as a father who
and a guy who traveled around
all, you know, so many
weeks out of the year,
the idea that I kind of liked it.
You know, I kinda liked it,
but you can tell that the long-term impact
is not ultimately healthy.
We, you know, they have to be with friends
and they have to be,
we all have to be with friends.
We all have to move our bodies around and,
but it's, you know, we know
our personalities now so well,
you know, you can almost do like
hand gestures, a little facial, you know.
Like, oh, that one just
came down and, you know,
you can tell that, you know,
they're in a mood, leave him alone,
you know, kind of a thing.
- Yeah.
Did that catch you off guard?
Do you think you have a,
like you and your family
have more of an appreciation
for that now or was that
something that you think
was always there and
just kind of continued?
- Well, they all had their ecosystem
and I would come in and
out of the ecosystem
based on my travels and
all the work I was doing.
So I definitely felt
their little cocoon
expanded to include me during it.
But then in a weird way, you know,
I started doing from
home work with my union.
You know, zoom kinda made
lots of things possible
that weren't possible beforehand
so I applied to American University.
I started doing this thing.
And a weird way we kind
of like went to our
mental neutral corners anyway.
- Yeah.
- Even though we were, I
wanted to learn the guitar.
So I'd be upstairs, you know,
with the door closed playing guitar.
And it's amazing after 10,000 hours
of guitar blank how bad I still am.
And they're very patient, you know,
they'll come up and go
to bed and I'm like,
"Wait, you got to listen to this song."
You know, they're like, "Yeah,
I'm not gonna listen
to it, it's all right."
But you know, we
for a while when COVID started we all ate
sort of like regular meals together,
like normal people.
But then we kind of all live
like we're in a fish tank
or, you know, like we all just kind of
graze and do what we're doing.
So it's amazing how we've,
settled back into like
where we were beforehand
in a lot of ways.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, it sounds like you
all were flexible too.
I mean, you kind of
readjusted in this mode...
- Well, we were lucky.
We were lucky in,
I will forever be grateful for
our particular circumstance
in this sort of thing.
You can see the rhythms
of your day and your week and your month.
You can see your family rhythms.
You can see your own
psychological rhythms.
You know, why on one day
am I feeling totally claustrophobic?
And like, I have to get out
and there's no reason to,
but and other days,
no there's, you know,
we want to go for a
drive just to get a sense
of what's going on in the outside world.
So like we're in the Mars Rover
and we're going out to explore.
You know, and like what,
how do we,
you know, no one got hurt physically.
I wondered about that a lot.
Like, what happens if
somebody falls down the stairs
or cuts themselves or
has some other, you know,
breaks a tooth or I don't know.
Something like it's been a
blessing that nobody's been
really injured over
the course of the time.
But because of that,
we've basically been in this
little behavioral experiment.
And, you know, I,
yeah, I mean, I think
we'll be unpacking it
for the rest of our lives.
I as our family member, I've
been the sort of first to go.
And so and they, you know,
we have this long talk about like
you're gonna go into in this movie
and then you're gonna come back
and you're going to be like,
there's no such thing as
COVID, let's just keep going.
I'm like, probably because
it was in the south
where I was working,
but I said, no, you know,
of course I'll be respectful
and it's all I'm masked it all doing
what we're supposed to do.
But when I came back, I
started looking at them
and judging them a little bit.
Like you guys, you can't,
your paradigm is.
You're in a locked paradigm
that's not in your own interest.
You've got to break out of it.
And then there was like
this civil war in there.
This cold civil war in our house about,
you know, whether what's
it's time to do and not do.
But, you know, I'm taking
this economics class
and I'm like, come up with,
you know, things in everyday life
that reflect some of the economics,
you know, principles that we're studying.
And one of the things
is like my whole life,
I've as a parent,
it's been about saving
money for their college.
That's been my life.
So save money for college.
Save money for college.
And we've been lucky to do it.
Some years we couldn't,
other years they could.
But by the time, the first one,
by the time Allie got
ready to go to college
we've been able to kind of be there.
But now that Elizabeth is in
her second year at Pepperdine,
her whole first year virtual.
And you're looking at this bucket of money
that you worked so hard to save
over two decades basically,
and you go, boy, I've never
thought of this before.
We are like, well, I can just
park that money in a house.
I just buy her a house.
And somehow and,
so you start looking at like,
what are she joined a sorority?
Its like she,
she knew that it wasn't okay
that we're so segregated from people.
So she did it as a way
to make sure that she had
this virtual community so
that when we come out of it
she'll be able to go back into it.
Which just is very sensible.
But it seemed to me that
that activity,
that discretionary activity
that is so outside of her normal mode
is the thing that's worth
not buying the house for.
I want her to go to college,
but my worldview has
you know, just paused to allow
other things to come into it.
What do we value?
Why do we value?
What does the opportunity
cost of doing that forego?
You know, so anyhow,
they're very patient with me.
(all laughing)
But yeah and I hope everybody is
going through those kinds of
evaluations in their mind.
I think it wakes people up.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I think just having that awareness
like you mentioned too,
of all the different values that we have.
And I think it's given us another way
to actually look at those in the mirror
and think about what our values
and what our worldview are, you know.
Cause even as you mentioned,
when you left and came back,
it seemed like there was a shift there
there's a little bit of a riffle.
I mean, obviously we could get into that,
just all the different covert perspectives
and different pockets of
the country but then just,
you know, even that you've
caught yourself in that like
judging mode...
- We the film that I did
the crew all has to be double vaxed.
The crew has to all wear masks.
Anybody that's interacting with actors
because actors have makeup
on that the masks can
smudge and mess up.
So they have to have the
masks and the shield.
You know, there's not,
there's all, you know,
people are having temperature
checks in the morning.
There was all these like
super rigorous controls.
But the second I stepped outside
and I didn't have a mask on,
it was like no time.
(all laughing)
That was fun.
- Yeah, yeah.
That's exactly what happens.
So I mean, it's that tension
too between because I mean,
so the other thing is you were there.
I assume you didn't get sick.
But a different scenario,
if something had happened,
you caught COVID
and then how that could have
also changed your worldview.
And I think some of that
has also played out in a lot of ways too.
- My brother and I we're talking because,
I'm in Sweden now and no
one in Sweden wears masks,
No one.
So I'm interacting with say
a thousand people, right?
Or directly rely,
you know, I mean you're in a hall
where there's 10,000 people
but directly interacting with
a couple of hundred maybe.
And he's interacted with like six people,
but he's like, if I get COVID,
Sean gets COVID because he
was interacting with people,
it's justifiable because
he was making money.
If I get COVID because I
was visiting my friends,
then it was just,
it was a discretionary
like error or something.
So there's these kinds of psychological,
like games that you play
with yourself that go into,
you know, and so in
economics there's this thing,
they call it homo economicus.
And that's the ideal rational actor.
The entity that will
make whatever interests,
not gonna tip at a restaurant because
it's not in that person's interest
unless you have a different relationship.
So you just start realizing
like what, you know,
what is our obligation to each other?
- Yeah.
- What is our obligation to each other to,
and how we, you know, the
only kind of leadership,
the best kind of leadership to me
is the only kind of
leadership of that by example.
And what happens when you set
an example that, you know,
doesn't line up with the stated...
- Yeah.
There's so many layers of that too,
because like your own
perspective about justifying
why you're doing what you're doing
versus what other people are thinking
versus on what the outcomes.
'Cause like you and your
brother kind of depended on,
you know, if you got COVID,
if he had gotten COVID
different perspectives
on the outcomes that justification,
like all that kind of all mixed together.
I think that can,
it's good for us...
- Then I have all of these friends,
you know, there's different
threads that I'm on
and on one of these threads that I'm on
with a lot of very intelligent,
very, you know, well-educated people,
there's a steady drum beat of
antagonism towards public
policy with regard to COVID
and the memes and the videos and the
things that come through.
They're all smart people.
These people I'm describing
who are putting it forward.
So there's always like some
element in what's being conveyed
that gives you pause.
You know, and then I go back to my team
and I'm like, "Hey, hun,
what do you think of this?"
And they're like, "Wow, you can give any"
And you're like, well, what
are we allowed to discuss?
You know, what is the conspiracy?
You know, conspiracy theory
is something that any
two or three people come up with.
You know, when is it
bad and when is it,
you know, like prudent?
I don't know.
- And it's hard to find the truth
beneath everything too with all the,
I mean, so how quickly someone can just
say something that goes viral
that somehow becomes truthful
even though it's completely nonfactual.
It doesn't navigate through that whole...
- And the mental strain
that it puts on people of
goodwill trying to navigate
those decisions and
those emotions and those,
you know, particularly
when you have people
that you're responsible for.
Now, when it comes to
rebuilding a society.
Mental society,
where we can, you know,
relate with each other just takes
commitment and focus.
And I think, and it's exhausting.
- Yeah.
And I know you've talked
about that before too,
how you see mental health
as the biggest challenge
that we have as a nation,
especially coming out of the pandemic.
So just thinking about, you know,
some of the things you've
done in the community like
what's been your idea of ways to
kind of help people move
through that because it is,
you know, a lot of people
kind of talked about
the second wave being kind
of the mental health crisis.
Not that the crisis wasn't there before,
but just the additional
strain of all the isolation.
And there's the fear factor people...
- Maybe the COVID has made it easier
for people to have a mental
health discussion because
on some macro level I hope
because nobody did anything
quote, unquote, wrong.
A lot of times in the stigma game,
the idea of starting to talk
about one's mental health
connotes failure or, you know,
that it means that you've,
you know, that there's
been some bad behavior,
bad thinking, bad choices, bad,
I don't know what, but that
in some way you are responsible,
not just for like, you
know, the decisions you make
and the ramifications
of your decisions but
you're responsible for the very nature of
whether or not you're healthy.
Your food choices, your
exercise, your sleep regimen,
all those kinds of things
that go into health.
But there's, you know,
that's that stigma.
And now everybody is
allowed to talk about,
wow, what does it mean that
you did night, you know,
18 months differently
than any one in society
for the last couple of hundred years,
even through world wars
nothing happened like this.
I asked my father, if you
remember the depression, he's 91.
And he said, he remembered it very well.
He remembered bread lines.
Since dad was the scientist,
but he remembered certain things.
And I said," What's worse, that or this?"
He said this by a mile.
He goes, you,
when someone was in trouble
during the depression,
you could help them.
Now, the best thing you
can do to help somebody
was stay away from them.
So that paradigm is in inhuman.
It's not human.
When else in human history,
I mean, there have been
other plagues and other,
you know, mass health events and stuff,
but on this scale, you know.
So, but any anyhow what
do I do in a weird way,
You know, "Lord Of The Rings"
maybe the biggest thing I ever do.
I do a lot of other things like
specific to giving talks and
my organization and stuff like that but,
people, you know, there's a
great speech in the two towers.
And Sam's looking out and he goes,
"It's like in the great tales, Mr. Frodo.
So like in the great stories, Mr. Frodo,
Full of darkness and danger they were,
and sometimes you didn't
want to know the end
because how could the end be happy?
How could the world go on the way it was
when so much bad had happened?
But in the end, it's only a
passing thing that shadow.
Even darkness must pass
on a new day will come
and when the sun shines, it
will shine out the clearer.
Those are the stories
that stayed with you.
That meant something even
if you were too small
to understand why.
I think Mr. Frodo, I do understand now.
Folk in those stories had lots
of chances to turn them back.
Only they didn't.
They kept going because they
were holding onto something."
"What are we holding onto Sam?"
"That there's some good left
in this world, Mr. Frodo.
and it's worth fighting for"
One of the greatest speeches
ever in the history of,
you know, drama or whatever.
I'm so lucky I got to
be the one to say that.
And, you know, when you,
when I'm giving talks
mental health speeches
to mental health organizations
which I do all the time,
something about relating my
direct personal experience
and reflecting the direct
personal experience of people
in the audience.
Often people will ask
questions and that's great
because then you can engage
a little bit like that.
There's a sense of
security that people feel.
There's a sense of relief that people feel
not to be alone in a moment.
And then I'll do that speech
or then we'll play a little bit
of that speech or something like that.
And you realize that like
they're, you know, in and of
itself that speech is powerful.
I've had thousands.
Literally thousands of people
over 20 years, tell me.
Well, let's say hundreds
at the least say, you know,
it saved their life
and it got them through
a dark time in their life that they,
you know, it gave them inspiration.
It gave them hope to go on and it it'd be
it gives, that speech gives
a prescription, you know.
There is good.
I don't know. Is there
good? Isn't there good?
Well, and that idea the
concept there is good
and it's worth fighting for.
My mental health
kind of exploration is
now is kind of graduated
into not that it's worth fighting for,
but like how do you fight?
- Yeah.
(Sean chuckling)
- You know?
So which is, you know, I've got solutions,
but they're just suggestions
that people have to find
them for themselves.
With that movie and then,
you know, just,
I want my observations
about my mother's life
and her experience and
my life and my experience
with my family.
And the fact that people
are willing to listen
a little bit closer
because they recognize you
from a movie or something.
That was my mom's mission.
Her mission was to
de-stigmatize mental health.
So I,
I steer into that space where just
people like, well, I don't
know if you're comfortable.
Like, if I'm comfortable?
When I was like 12,
my mom was saying stuff
that you're like, "Mom,
how did you say like,
you didn't get permission
before you told that anecdote, you know."
Like, well, you know, and
I'm sorry on the one hand,
but then people come up to
me later in like saying,
you know, your mother's
book saved my life.
You know, your mother, her fight,
her tenacity,
her, you know,
her Moxie basically is
I gave them inspiration.
And so we, you know...
- There are time when
people weren't really
talking about it much, at
least in her profession.
- Well, the profession itself had advanced
to a certain level at that point.
Her diagnosis.
I mean, if you think,
when she got diagnosed as a,
I think it was, was it
called manic depression then?
Now it's called bipolar disorder.
There was something else.
There was another one too.
She was afraid of like
padded rooms and straight
jackets, and electroshock therapy,
and being ostracized, and
being given Thorazine.
And like, in her mind,
when you're mentally unwell,
you go away.
So the vocabulary, the science,
the psychopharmacology,
had all, you know, met her
where she was in her 40s.
And then she decided to just
kind of like pick up this flag,
like on the battlefield and
just start waving it around
because she was so grateful that,
she also saw it as a success
strategy for herself.
That if she took
ownership of her diagnosis
and her treatment and her, you know, her
journey from places where
she behaved very badly
in a lot of ways in
front of a lot of people,
to someone who did that less and less.
And, you know,
if she took ownership of that journey
that she would sort of get credit for it.
He would get credit for it,
from herself, from her family.
We would probably the last
thing to give her credit for it
because there was a disconnect between
the authority with which she spoke
and the truth of how she lived
and you're like there's a gap there.
But it didn't matter to the people
who she was communicating with.
They were inspired.
But that sort of empowerment
track that she was on,
I think
was in terms of.
Larry King was always was, you know,
the first cable news kind
of nighttime news anchor.
I mean, you'd had the,
you have Peter Jennings and
Dan Rather, and the other guy,
but who are your kind of like, you know,
male, white, of a certain age, you know,
disseminating the news during the week
to let you know that
the world was okay and,
you know, whatever.
So, but Larry King was the
first like talk show guy to do
those sorts of issues.
War and stuff.
And every time something would happen
in the mental health space,
Mariel Hemingway would be
on to deal with alcoholism,
Rosalynn Carter would come
on to talk about depression,
and my mom was there
to talk about bipolar.
And there were, you know,
now we're all into seeing
panels of speakers on TV,
but at the time they were
doing it, that was pretty rare.
So she was, you know, if somebody,
it was usually in response
to something horrible
that would happen, a shooting
or something like that,
but she would get a third of the time
to respond to those issues.
And she educated herself
well enough, you know,
laypersons education about it.
But, you know, sufficient to impress
Psychiatric Institute of
America who gave her a big award
and pharmaceutical companies
who had her, you know,
work with them and stuff.
So I do have my, you mentioned
the Run3rd running thing.
We ended up creating a nonprofit
called the Run3rd Alliance.
That's how you and I met because we,
it had to go virtual. It's a 5K.
It's a series of
afterschool running program
for elementary school kids.
So fifth, sixth graders.
Fourth, fifth, sixth graders who
just a little bit of a very low cost
structured afterschool experience that,
you know, running.
That's just so good for kids
to get that physical energy.
and then to connect them
conceptually like with
their parents a little bit
and then with the community abroad.
And then it culminates in a 5K run at the,
it's in Mesa, Arizona.
We have like 10 schools, 12
schools and Mesa, Arizona.
And Red Mountain High
on their football field
we set up one of those 5K balloon things
and we bring a lot of people,
you would get all kinds
of sponsors to come out,
and it's a beautiful thing.
So we had to go virtual because of the,
because of COVID and it occurred to us
as we were trying to figure out like,
you know, the fundraiser to be ready to.
I mean, all the programs just folded
when the close to shut up
was like, okay, well now.
So do we want them to come back online?
We don't really have the
infrastructure set up for that.
We need money to be able to do it.
So, but as we were putting
together the virtual 5K,
it just became clear
that one of the things
we could use the moment for
was to engage these families.
Mostly lower income families
with mental health concepts.
And so, you know, when my mom died.
Right after she died,
I cooked up this idea
of the mental health,
Patty Duke Mental Health Project.
We never raised enough
money to actually be able to
launch it as a proper
instrument, legal instrument,
but we raised some money
and I was like, well,
let's put some money towards
facilitating a little dialogue with these,
and it's not a dialogue, but like,
how can we flow resources to these folks?
And so we,
and I really appreciated the
fact that you can talk to us
about how to think about some of that.
So those are the,
you know, mental health
speeches which I do a lot.
And those, and that little
thing that I just described,
or the kind of big
ticket things that I do.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, it was definitely appreciated.
I mean, I was thinking back
to something you said earlier
about just a shift.
It's almost like people
have more permission
to talk about it.
Because, you know, you
talked about when people
are before it's,
a lot of times saying,
what did you do wrong?
You know, this happened to you,
you're at fault.
Have you noticed?
Is that openness still there
when you're engaging the community
with the Run-Through Alliance
when you're talking to,
are there still some pushback?
Like how do you navigate
that as someone who grew up
with someone who struggled
with mental health
and saw kind of both sides of that?
- I don't want to report
what I think I see.
(all chuckling)
what I think I see are,
I think there are,
the resources that are available to people
are so much more than people realize.
There are some great resources.
So if people are in need,
everyone is in need.
But if, to some extent or other,
but, you know, if it gets to
a point where people feel like
they need to, you know, talk
to a counselor or, you know,
you know, seek some sort of a diagnosis
or something like that,
if they ask a little
bit, there are routes.
You know, they'll get routed
to places where they might be able to get
something that they can afford.
You know, cause a lot of times there's
people that are worried
about the expense of
that sort of thing, you know.
But I mean she's,
I haven't really tried it,
but that Michael Phelps promoted thing
about talk therapy now kind of a thing,
you're like, well, that's, there you go.
That's a lot of times
mostly would be, you know,
what people need at least
to start us function.
So, but I see antagonisms
developing along the lines of how people
are coming out of COVID.
- Wow.
- And I see it
making people's communication
a little fragile.
So I think we could do well to start.
You know, I had a friend
come to LA from New York
and he was,
he was clearly kind of back
in the saddle, you know.
Some people are just, you know,
a lot of them, I mean, look,
stadiums of people are going to,
you know, like the country
is back for, you know,
in a serious way,
but, you know, people's
mentality is still there.
So he came out and I kept
saying, you know, listen Mike,
the way my wife and kids are,
they don't want me to, you know,
go mix and mingle in the
world and then come back
into their like protected bubble.
And he, this my good friend
and he like couldn't,
he couldn't work with it for awhile
until I kind of said it forcefully.
I'm like, look, it will be
upsetting to them if I do that,
if I come and meet you on somewhere
outside with Matt, whatever.
And it's so and he finally was like,
"Okay, I totally understand. That's fine."
But there was a,
there was we did have to
navigate that little space and
I wasn't even the one
who was worried about it.
So I then had to turn around,
I had the static with him
and then I had to turn around
to my guys and be like, "Listen, you guys,
this is the environment that
people are operating in.
So now behaving responsibly
at the extreme end that
you're wanting to is,
you know, has consequences.
And we have to understand
what those consequences are."
And then they want to challenge them to.
They want, you know, they want
friends, they want at school,
they want a lot of things but,
I just noticed that there's a look and
a kind of furtive look in people's eyes
when they ask questions about,
you know, what's going on post COVID.
And I it's makes me sad because I'm,
you know, I don't know if I'm an empath
in the clinical sense
of it or the whatever
metaphysical sense of it,
but I'm very in tune with what
people are thinking and feeling.
And, you know,
God, I remember when there was in 1992,
after the verdict within
the Rodney King trial
and the LA riots started.
The 92 LA riots started.
I remember driving to the grocery store
and we were like, okay, well, let's,
you know, let's get some
do a little grocery shopping
because it's going to
be a few days probably
until this all calms down.
And I get to the grocery store
and people in the parking lot
were not observing normal rules.
They were not behaving normally.
They were parking a skew.
You know, they pull into the
parking lot and they'd stop
and they'd get out.
And, you know,
you get 20 or 30 people who do that
and the parking lot looks
like in Japan, you know.
So we go in and people are,
they're not in a,
they're not in a panic mode yet,
but there's this simmering feeling.
And so we got and whatever
few little things.
We weren't gonna like,
you know, order anything,
but the few things we got,
we get in line and we're standing there
and the person checking out
the items is not looking up.
Or it's just only looking up
to the extent they need to.
And I could see the person's name was,
I don't know, Tom or something like that.
I'm like, "Hey Tom, how you doing, man?
How are things going?"
And he looked up and he was,
and you could feel
everyone around settled.
Somebody talked normal,
Somebody, you know, there was a,
there was still a sense of like,
we know things aren't right
but how are you is a
question about normalcy.
And we'll we're okay.
You know, we're holding it together,
reinforces the idea of social cohesion.
And so at this current moment,
this thing that I'm noticing is like,
people's preset is something negative
or at least skeptical.
And so it's a little bit of
like an emotional barrier
that you have to climb over.
It's fast, it's subtle,
you can't really, you know,
to the untrained eye you might
not know what's going on.
But I just figured that, you know,
Thanksgiving is coming
in a couple of weeks.
I don't know when this,
when your listeners are going to hear this
sort of Christmas, the
holiday seasons season.
And you know, it's bad
enough if you're one,
you know, if one uncle's a Republican
and the other one's a Democrat
and you just know like, oh my God,
they're just going to be going on that,
you know, and so forth.
But now everyone,
most people can just get
away in those social settings
of saying like,
you know, well, I don't
really talk about politics.
You know what, I haven't really
paid much attention to it.
Or they're all the same anyway.
Or you can, you know, its the
safe harbor in dismissiveness,
but when it comes to COVID,
everybody's got a...
- That's one of those things.
(Sean laughing)
- Yeah its just devised
and I think you're right.
Cause everybody's riding, I mean,
like you talked about what the King,
Rodney King is there's just a
level of tension and anxiety
that everybody's riding.
I think it's a huge
variety in how much people,
or how much we're willing
to acknowledge that
in our interactions.
I think some of us are very
keenly aware that it's there
and it's affecting how we interact
and navigate in the world.
And some of us aren't as keenly aware
and I was just kind of
seeing the outcome of it
in those environments.
And then things kind of boil over.
So like you were talking about me,
just that community aspect
is taking time to step back
and say, how are you?
And, you know, just those little things
it makes a huge difference
cause it's, you know,
this is kind of a unique shared
experience in that sense.
- Well, I feel like these
kinds of conversations
And I don't even know what
other forms it takes but
it takes time to think through a process.
And there everybody's
got other stuff going on.
So to help, to give people tools.
Like, hey, if you find
yourself in this situation,
here's the way, you know,
this is what's at stake
and here's some possible
ways for you to navigate it.
You know, in the economics.
In behavioral economics is this last
chapter we've been looking at
and there's all these kinds of prompts.
They call them nudges.
Do you know what nudges are?
Nudges in society.
Things like
if the default setting at your work
is that you're opted into a savings plan,
where they withhold savings,
or you're opted in already.
So you're not opted in your
the default setting is your
participating in some healthcare plan
or something like that.
You have to choose not to do it.
People are behavioral tendencies,
are if we were more aware of them
and the ways that I'm learning about it
in these classes I'm taking,
I think we might, we might,
people should just know that there are
thinking has been done along the lines
of what most of us are
feeling and thinking.
And it's not that far away
to be able to access that thinking.
You don't have to read the whole book.
You don't have to listen
to the whole audio book.
You don't have to, you
know, fully go there.
There are ways because
people are impatient,
you know, and where people
choose to put their intention,
their, you know,
the substance of their life.
what they do, you know,
But we could all, you know.
The seatbelt light.
if you don't put your seatbelt on,
there's an actual light that goes off
that tells you and the sound
and they make it mandatory that, you know.
And the death rate in the public policy
of doing that drives it down.
Like what is there in
the mental health space
that could be a blinking light
that lets you know, like, oh,
actually you're gonna
cause a lot less expense
to the health care
system if you, you know,
get a good night's sleep or you,
you know, you eat a
sandwich when you're hungry
and you don't let yourself
spiral out of control
because the truth is you're
hungry, you know like.
- I think the way that's the key question.
Now I think that we're
still trying to figure out
the best way to do that.
I mean, I think part of it
is having people like you
who are sharing honestly, you know,
about what you experienced
growing up and trying to
put that in front of a lot
of different audiences.
People have lived experiences,
making sure that they share,
but really to kind of get it in brains.
I think that's the key piece
because it's funny, you know,
as you're talking about the sleep.
So my dad's actually asleep
position and he came on,
you know, this podcast
a couple episodes back
and he was just talking
about some of those things.
Like how sleep affects your overall health
and your mental health and the importance
of getting good rhythms.
And, you know, just some
of the little things
that can make a huge difference.
But if there's a way for us to kind of
really have that permeate
into, do you have any ideas?
I'm curious.
I mean, as someone who thought
about this a little bit.
- My sleep schedule.
Well, I mean,
is being honest with yourself
about what's going on in your environment
that's actually affecting those things.
I mean, I,
my sleep schedule,
I noticed I was like
going to sleep at three
and four in the morning.
And, you know, I'd wake
up in the morning tired
or I'd wake up at 11,
you know, I'd get my six or seven hours.
I was just getting them like an hour
and it's not like it was affecting my,
I mean, my work.
I'm professional if I have a job
and I need to be up at
seven in the morning,
you know, I get up at six
and I'm like, I'm fine.
But I have one of those jobs as an actor
where most of the time
I'm actually not working.
So really it's like, woo,
what do you want to do with your life?
And I realized that when
that I experienced a
certain kind of stress
associated with my wife and kids.
And when they, everybody
would go to sleep,
all of a sudden it was like jazz hours.
Like this is my time.
You know like this is time where,
you know, and so I would just, you know,
maybe even just watch
movies on TV, you know,
like watch movies.
Nothing, even then, you know,
sometimes the same
movie I'd seen 10 times.
But there were some,
there must've been something about that.
And then like when, oh
my gosh, when COVID hit,
I became like a sun worshiper.
I would set my clock,
my daily mental clock,
based on the half hour or
I would go out and sit down
on the patio furniture or walk around
with my shirt off in the backyard.
Like in shorts.
Like, you know, they're like,
"Dad, what are you doing?"
- You can't do that
dad. That's not allowed.
- I heard my dad cried for sure.
But like, I would literally
feel so much better
and sleep so much regularly.
My circadian rhythms when I was like,
had a kind of sun,
you know, regular sun.
I then once we got to a
point where I was like, guys,
I'm now going to go like
for long walks or runs.
So we can pick a route
where you guys are comfortable with it,
but I'm not going to not do that.
Otherwise, you know, I have to do that.
So if you need me to move out,
you're going to kick me out.
If I keep me up, I'm going
for a six mile walk right now,
that's what's happening.
And so we came up with
a compromise at work.
But when I would do that,
when I would get 6, 8, 9,
10 miles of a walk in a day,
sleep like a baby.
Eat better.
Actually I could eat like crap afterwards
'cause I feel like I was like
I was like burn the rest...
- Oh, you justified it.
- But I, you know,
mental sleep hygiene,
your dad's to have his asleep.
You know, it's weird here.
It's 3:30 here.
So have you seen any,
have any of the ships gone by yet?
- I haven't seen anything yet.
- We've picked the wrong hour to do this
because like an hour these ships,
these massive really cool
ships are going to go
right by the window, but
it gets dark here now.
Like four by four o'clock
within the next half hour,
40 minutes, it's dark.
- That's it?
- That acts with the mind.
- That's true.
- And I, but there's,
I found a place where I can park the car.
The Swedish they're so organized.
Everything is so well
like, you know, organized.
No joke.
And there's these walkways
that are really well lit.
And I can go for like a five mile walk.
And I'll go, I'll put on my coat.
It's cold out.
It's like, you know, 32 degrees up,
but I'll get my clothes
on. I'll go for a walk.
And I'm moving one's
physical body outside is a,
and drinking water.
Those are my two, you know,
some people can take
certain drugs, you know.
My mom, you know, hers was lithium.
She was very religious about it.
She talked about it but whatever
drug therapy or talk therapy
or whatever go through
as they're building their
wellness strategy for themselves.
Moving and it's hard for people
who can't move their bodies.
It's hard, you know,
you know why like, in,
in a convalescent homes,
they wheeled them out.
The patients out to be in the sun
for a certain period of time.
So I would just encourage people
to find outdoor time doing anything.
- Yeah.
And so many pieces of that too.
Cause I mean, your extras
like the way the exercise
impacts the brain which makes it,
you know, easier for us to just
kind of navigate through it
or just being in the sun
having a regular schedule.
It sounds like what you've done
is just found out what those are for you.
You know, for your mom
it might be medication...
- Well, we've isolated.
- Yeah?
- I think often about my
wife's family in Indiana.
Her father was a firefighter
and clean operator.
Her mom worked in a foundry.
These are working class people.
And a lot of times the
conversations about men
it's changed now.
Now in that community, CVS
is right down the street.
Everybody knows where to go.
They go into a doctor to get their meds,
like people are oriented towards it now.
I think the next step
in the mental health,
you know, game is,
is for people to start
refining their questions and
raising their expectations
for what their own,
you know, capabilities are
and managing that process.
So, but yeah.
What can I say?
The other thing is to move
away from sleep for a second.
There's a lot of discussion now.
I just gave a talk with a group called,
I think they were called
Brain Health or something.
What was the phrase they used?
It was so good.
It just has to do with language.
The vocabulary surrounding
the conversation of mental health.
The mental wellness.
The mental illness.
And I find that one of the things
I'm able to do in my speech is
because I just don't care.
I mean, I always say at the
beginning of my speeches
to mental health organizations, groups,
community groups, or whatever,
like I'm not a professional, you know,
you have to seek your own, you know,
professional medical guidance
and everything else but
I'll speak candidly about
what I think and feel.
And one of the things that I
speak to is I'm very critical
of the mental health
corporate and the mental
health medical community.
Because I think the language that is used,
the general temperament has improved
I think over the last 25, 30
years where people's, you know,
healthcare providers,
mental health providers
are genuinely interested in
contributing to the
wellness of the person.
They're not just like
dealing with a problem,
but even well-intentioned people
use phrases that are suppressive.
And if we, you know.
You know, people with bipolar
disorder in particular,
like my area
are highly suggestible
and like really
highly in tune with judgment
and what's being said.
And, you know,
if the mind is going a
thousand miles an hour,
which it's want to do,
and you get like a little
monkey wrench thrown into it,
ooh, that's bad.
So people have to be accountable
for their own reactions
to what they hear.
But when you call someone,
there was a word that
I haven't heard as much
in the last few years,
but they were calling people sufferers.
A bipolar sufferer.
You're like, come on, man.
We gotta do better than that.
Because if you're a bipolar,
is it like a broken arm? Does it mend?
If you have a bipolar mood disorder,
is there a fixed stop point
or are you being given a death sentence
when you're told that you
have a bipolar mood disorder.
And if you're a bipolar sufferer, well,
we've now consigned you to suffering
for the rest of your life.
And that is not accurate.
It's not an accurate thing to do.
You know, I mean, I think
people might feel like,
well, at least someone has empathy.
You know, if you say someone's a sufferer,
you go oh I don't want
you to be suffering.
I see that you're suffering, I hear you,
I feel that you're suffering.
I wanna help take action
that can help alleviate it.
But there's just a
conversancy that happens.
And there's like,
there's optimistic speak and there's...
- Yeah, just the little things.
I think that's so important like to have
even some of these like back
and forth conversations.
I think they are critical
because that makes to your point,
I think, you know, within
some of the train circles,
people are trying to get away from.
Are trying to pay attention to their own,
not that they weren't before,
but their own body language
and their responses
and how that influences
people that they're talking with.
But I think like just to
have this type of a level
of candid conversation is critical
because even within the field,
you know, there's been a shift from
trying to get away from
saying you are bipolar.
Like that defines you.
- Right.
- And obviously it has lots
of negative consequences
to try and to say, this is
something that someone has,
but as you pointed out
even that can be a shift.
I think people are now trying to say,
well you are struggling.
Someone who has bipolar is
struggling with bipolar.
Is suffering with bipolar.
But then to your point,
if people don't have these conversations
and don't even think about
what that word suffer does
or how that's being
interpreted by the person.
So I feel like this has to be,
I don't think it's there enough,
but it has to be an ongoing conversation
between clinicians,
scientists, family members,
and those who are working
through to get both sides.
- One of the things that I
think can help is if people
orient themselves into the,
to the premise that like
people who are having an issue
can successfully navigate the issue
'cause here are ways for it to be there.
So it doesn't, you know,
the thing that's hard is,
you know, usually there's when,
the moment at which people talk about,
focus,
think about, seek treatment or whatever,
there's usually crisis involved.
So the what's interesting
to think about, I think
is to note that like a
crisis moment on a timeline
does not have to define like the endpoint.
We've been many of the
other points along that.
Along that continuum.
So, you know, navigate, you know,
mental health challenges, you know.
So the one group was talking
about, you know, brain health.
That's what they were call.
They're called Brain Health.
And they're like, the
brain is an organ like,
you know, your heart is an organ.
You have to have heart health,
you have to have liver health,
kidney health,
you have to brain health.
- [Addy] Yep.
- And
so, you know,
they're such complex
instruments our brains.
What an amazing thing.
What an amazing thing
that the neurological
kind of carnival that's happening.
You know, I mean, I'm at
an age now where memory.
I'm starting to, you know,
you know, I'm wondering if I've topped up.
Like that's it.
I've kept my memory things like, you know,
my father's 91, his memory is incredible.
He somehow finds pathways
for ideas to get to names or numbers.
You can spit out a number and
he can remember a number of things.
But I find that my recall, like,
so with the what's going on?
what's going on in the
chambers of my mind?
Is it starting to atrophy?
Is it starting to, you
know, I love my studies.
I love my studies.
I mean, my brain is so hard.
It's so hard and what I
know would have taken me,
you know, two hours to do in my early 20s
is taking six hours to do now that I'm 50.
And I don't know if that's just because,
I don't know why that is, but I
just marvel at the human mind and what's,
I hope that the technology and medicine
is accelerating quickly enough that,
I mean, you're young.
How old are you though? I see you got...
- 23.
- Not as young, yeah.
Not as young as I was.
- So I'm 50.
So by the time I'm 65, which is like what?
Is that official retirement age is
or retirement age is older now 70, 72.
I don't know.
Well, public policy is what I'm studying.
Like it doesn't, I'm an actor.
We never retire.
I'm retired every time I
finish a job I'm retired.
I'm coming out of retirement
because I got another job.
But the,
but your like, will there
be technologies available
to help stimulate the mind
or help repair the brain?
If that's something you're working on,
let me not distract you.
- People are working on it.
But to be honest, I mean,
it's one of those interesting topics
because some of the things we're learning
shouldn't be surprising in a sense,
but people are trying to understand,
okay, how this exercise
actually impacts process.
And even all the things
that, you know, being
I was not academically, but
being just engaged in things.
Deep conversations and
studies and things like that.
Just keeping your mind active
and all the positive effects that it has.
I mean, I don't study aging per se but
some of it is just looking
at those natural practices.
Those practice that we know we should do
that actually have positive
effects for our brains as well.
But in that sense, a lot of the research
that people are doing
and trying to figure out
what's happening when things go awry.
So when, you know, when dimension sits
and they're all timers are ways
that we can kind of prevent
some of those processes
and things like that.
And to be honest, some of the,
it's not a complete a hundred
percent protective effect,
but some of those things
like exercise and engaging in
intellectual activities also seem
to have some protective effects.
So people are looking
into how that's happening.
But I mean, that's an open
question, whether there'll be,
you know, therapeutic
interventions or technology to
that's, you know, the age old question of
not immortality but kind of keeping
our mental faculties in the
sense as long as we can.
- I mean, you know, we,
there are such dangers
associated with having eight
and a half billion people
on this little blue spinning rock.
You know, there are like our food supply.
Our, you know, I mean disease.
Like we've just been, you know,
like these kinds of
pandemics that you can have.
You know, just
the environment like pollution, you know.
All of there's so many
things that are really
just pressures weighing
down on civilization.
On humankind.
But one of the awesome things is that
really smart people like you
are working all over the world
on coming up with some of these kinds of
insights and, you know, therapies and,
you know, just.
So I hope I live long enough to be able to
see, you know, dementia will be great.
Wouldn't it be great if you could really
take the teeth out of dementia?
That'd be great.
And so, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know.
- And I think again, you
know, just kind of full circle
it all ties back to community too.
I mean, I loved how you
talked about just the impact.
I mean, yeah, there are so many people
and that community it feels
like it can go both ways.
And I think we've obviously
seen that in the last year,
like the positive effects of
what we need and community,
what we can learn from each other
and how that actually
impacts our brains too,
and helps it makes it easier
for us to kind of navigate
through life just the reward that comes
from those social interactions.
But now on the flip side, all the anxs
and antagonism, you know.
Even as you're talking about
some of the COVID rifts
that can also come from
being in community.
So, I mean, it's a little bit of both but
I mean, I think in a lot of ways,
like the research enterprise in a sense
has seen that as well.
Because often times not
to make it too global,
but scientists obviously
working community too.
We need community to kind
of have innovative ideas
and think about new ways of doing things,
but I feel like people gotta
a greater sense of that.
Because sometimes people
can just be like, well,
this is my project.
I'm going to go down this lane,
laser focused,
work on that.
But without having those tough
touch points and interactions,
just how much harder it was
for people to actually do
that work in isolation.
And so, in a sense it's like
an awakening of those who
are doing the work realizing,
"Oh yeah, we also need
that community too."
Even though we may be
studying these things,
we can't actually remove
ourselves from the equation.
And again, I was thinking about, you know,
as you're talking about your
mom and some of those things,
like the importance of community
just in terms of mental health.
Like are we having conversations
across the board with different folks
who can actually inform how
we talk about mental health?
You know, are people
trying to do one thing
and talk about things in a better way,
but actually making it more difficult
for people who are kind
of going through it.
So I think it's all critically important.
So as you continue in this word that any,
like any words of wisdom for us as we,
you know, try and think towards
getting to a better place to
just how we talk about
and address mental health.
Like both the wellness aspect
and some of the challenges.
I mean, it drops a lot
of nuggets already but.
- Yeah, I mean,
there's this moment where
people go from being generous
to being selfish.
You know, if there's,
it's amazing when there's someone in need
how people are like, oh, help that person.
But then there's other ways in which
it's like people pull back.
And I think
we have to at the very least
see in ourselves when
we're leaning forward,
and when we're back with others.
With ourself too I guess a
little bit but with others.
Meaning just,
I talk about this a lot when
I'm giving speeches like,
you can only do so much.
You're only gonna be as
successful as you can be.
You can do everything right
and the person that you
want to be helpful with
can't go to work.
So the important thing is to
mourn the loss of,
you know,
that whatever level of
help you're trying to do
that isn't going to be a,
whatever that piece is that's a failure
more than the loss of that and then help.
Is in the quality of your
help will be based in,
you know, reality and based in
agency of the person that
you're trying to help
which is really
almost all the time like
the only way it works.
As if the person wants to move
in their direction for themselves.
You know, when people have
to protect themselves too,
because, you know, you can try,
there's a lifeguard analogy
where you swim the lifeguard
swims out and then the
person drowns the lifeguard
cause there's fuzzing out too much.
That happens a lot in
the mental health space.
So, you know, I think that
was sort of the second half.
What I should've said first is like,
just be willing to think.
You know, to be willing
to engage these ideas.
A lot of times the
subject matter is so big
that people it's just too
much to even think about.
But if you sort of empower yourself
that you can hear a little
bit and that's enough,
you don't have to like,
you know, you don't have
to overwhelm yourself.
You don't have to commit
yourself to a course of,
you're not going to be a
physician, you know, your in.
You know, maybe there'll be
useful piece of information
if you open your eyes in a certain moment
to a certain exchange that's happening
or something like that
and maybe there won't.
You know, I mean, I think people want,
you know, a hundred percent
return on time investment.
You know,
Oprah recommends a book,
you read that book,
you get the value from that book.
A hundred percent return, you know.
- It only works that way, you know.
- But sometimes people
will go to a website
or they'll go to a thing
and they'll invest a little bit of time.
And if there isn't return
on that investment,
somehow that's experienced is a defeat
or is a an unwilling sacrifice.
So I think if on the journey for our own
mental wellness and for,
I mostly think about others.
For myself,
you know,
for everybody, communication
is critical like you said.
Those kinds of
conversations, sensitivities,
it doesn't have to be conversations
if you just have sensitivities.
I was watching an episode of "Friends".
Oh, I was making a juice and
the thing that makes that
show work is that they all,
is they all lie to each other.
Throughout 10 seasons
they lie to each other,
they make mistakes at each other,
they compromise each other, whatever.
But ultimately what always
brings those characters
back to each other is they're
listening to each other,
and they are sensitive to each other.
And I feel like if we're sensitive to
our own words we're speaking to others.
If we protect ourselves,
if we recognize that
we're really sensitive
to what somebody else is saying, you know.
Somebody comes into your environment
and you're like, I'm not
gonna like this person,
light me up right now.
I'm just not going to let it happen.
And, you know, then they say something,
boom and you're off to
the races mentally, yeah.
You know, you have to develop.
My wife's grandfather was always,
late grandfather he died. He was 86.
I think he died 20,
more than 25 years ago.
I mean, 24 years ago.
He was always MacGyvering stuff.
You know what I mean?
Like I at one point I
walked out in our garage.
He was staying with us in
our little two bedroom house
in Sherman Oaks cause he
left the winter in Indiana,
he couldn't handle it.
So they came out with us and he would
open the garage and sit in
the chair looking at traffic.
Looking at the traffic
in the neighborhood.
He by 7:30, he could tell
you everyone's business.
- Wow.
- But he walked over to the tool chest
and he had rigged up like a,
a coat hanger
with the thing and another thing
and he was using it to hang his keys.
And I looked at it and I was like,
this old timer has just
like entertained himself
with coming up with his little thing.
And there were a million things like that.
If you went and looked at his toolbox
in his shed in Indiana,
there were a million things like that.
I think our mental
health can be like that.
We could come up with little
strategies that will like
help us in a moment or maybe it won't.
And maybe it helped us at one point
and it's not gonna help
us now and that's fine.
But that
spirit of innovation
that people have for objects,
if we find some way to do
that with our mind, you know,
I mean, I suppose if you're
ADD like how many times you,
where do you put the things on the thing
it matters or something but,
you know, what if you said something there
and you say every time I see that
I'm gonna say I love myself.
I mean, I don't know
whatever but whatever it.
Play games come up with little,
because what's fun is
you'll get lost in it
in some little games.
Some little technique you're
coming up with for yourself
to be able to like,
you know, pass the time
and make yourself calm yourself
or get yourself like going, you know.
You know, I know
because I was sleeping late all the time.
I could see where the,
we had a Palm tree in our back backyard.
And I could tell where the shadow was
in the Palm tree every day, right?
When I wake up, I looked
up and I'd be like
so bummed at the shadow
is what's over this way
cause I knew it meant like I had slept
like it was past noon or something.
And then, so what I would
do is I would look out,
and when the Palm tree got,
when the shadow of the Palm tree got
to this one particular thing,
I would get up and go run.
- Wow.
- I use the shadow of the Palm tree
as my prompts to get up and go running.
It's so stupid.
I don't think I've ever told anybody.
- Yeah it works.
- Right, so what happens is...
- You've started a rhythm for yourself
and then your brain is expecting that
and then you just go with it.
- And then someone will discover it.
You know, someone will be like,
if they'll see you thinking
about something or you'll be,
there has to be a spirit of play.
Is what I'm saying.
If you can have a spirit
of play about your own,
it can't just be about the
struggle and the thing.
There has to be some way
to engage other people.
And I know like my wife and I
she'll see something and she'll go,
"You're doing that with that, aren't you?
I'll be like, "Yeah."
And like, we'll just
it's like a little husband and wife thing
We're like, she knows me.
She knows that I'm like setting
my mental clock where I'm,
you know, petting my mental
mood in a certain way that,
you know, that she appreciate.
- Yeah.
I mean the research backs
you up just having that space
to play or do other things like
how resetting that is for us
and just protective in a lot of ways
and it helps people kind of
get through challenges too.
So your great grandfather,
he was onto something.
(Sean laughing)
- Yeah.
Oh my God.
Well, I appreciate you taking the time
and just starting all the
insights that you shared.
I know the listeners will
enjoy kind of hearing
what you've been up to in
the path and just, you know,
I really appreciate the way
you personalized it too.
Kind of took us on that journey.
So thanks so much for
taking the time to jump...
- Dr. Nii, you are a beautiful human being
and I wish you every
continued success with the,
with the podcast, with your family.
With the beautiful family
and you know how to get ahold of me
if you ever need me for anything.
(upbeat music)